foreign
24 2022 the day everything changed for
Ukraine
through the chaos one thing was clear
months of military buildup
would be no Bluff this was a Russian
invasion
from Belarus Southern Russia and Crimea
troops tanks and aircraft poured across
borders
fleeing the Russian Blitzkrieg civilians
crowded train stations and highways
hundreds of thousands of women and
children headed abroad men had to stay
my heart's being torn apart
I'm sorry
it's tough when families are separated
it's very hard
Ukraine was fighting for its survival as
a Sovereign Nation volunteers joined the
army and territorial defense groups
one of those who picked up a gun was
ihor
he helped defend earpin a key of suburb
that saw Fierce fighting
he who described to me what it had been
like
I had no fear I don't know why we were
all determined not to give up our land
we understood our weapons were weak
against their armor but we had
motivation
because of fierce Ukrainian resistance
Russia's Invasion wasn't going well
at the end of March after huge losses of
men and Machinery Russia abandoned its
attempt to seize Kiev
what they left behind shocked the world
butcher the most infamous but civilian
bodies were found in nearly every
settlement the Russians had occupied
often showing signs of torture and
execution
the seasons have carried Anastasia and
her grief through spring summer autumn
and now to Winter
when the Russians abducted her son it
didn't take him far just 200 meters down
the road to the pig farm where his body
was found
o I saw him being taken out which
there was a car outside they've taken
from one of the villagers when he
was the problem with this problem they
put him in and left I didn't know where
they were taken at half past five and
shot immediately that evening
as if he was sleeping
in the East the battle for Don Mass
became an attritional grind
but to the South Russia had more to show
for its efforts
on the as of Sea Coast finally fell to
the Russians in May a city of 400 000
people before the war lay in Ruins
but Ukraine Was preparing to strike back
it retook the kharkiv region in a
surprise September counter-offensive
that was followed by a strike on
Russia's bridge to Crimea and a forced
Russian Retreat from the city of her son
this was moscow's response running
shorts of military options Russia
launched drones and cruise missiles at
Ukraine's energy grid an attempt to
freeze the country into submission as
winter approached widespread blackouts
in Sub-Zero temperatures are a challenge
for everyone particularly those without
much money
dude Miller lives in a smoke blackened
bomb damaged apartment Block in here pin
yet she still counts herself lucky
to be honest my heart bleeds seeing
these ruins but we are alive we covered
the windows with film we had hope
because we have something left others
lost everything as 2022 ends ukrainians
leave behind them a year of
indescribable suffering but they take
with them a unity and a will to win
that's earned this country admiration
from around the world
there are still many people who doubt
that Ukraine can ultimately Prevail
against the might of Russia but few if
any of them come from this country ask
pretty much any Ukrainian what they
expect for 2023 and they only have one
answer Victory Rory Shannon's Al Jazeera
Kiev